in late 2009
i felt mature i was 29
and i saved like some capital started
from nothing i saved like
it's it's it's embarrassing to say but i
saved like 20 000 usd
and i said to myself okay what's now i
have a lot of money
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with ctec
welcome to 20 minute leaders let's talk
about personalized robots meet josie
wolf co-founder and chairman of tami
yossi is the chairman and co-founder of
temi the personal robot with 15 years of
experience in the field of robotics and
unmanned vehicles after serving the
special forces as an officer wolff
partnered with the lad levy to build
robo-team defense today hundreds of robo
teams robots are in daily practice
saving lives around the globe in 2016
yossi left the defense company for his
dream initiative temi to set to shake up
the market of personal robotics temi is
a premium designed video oriented
autonomous personal robot platform for
businesses and homes recently tami has
been selected by time magazine for
inventions of the year 2019.
you'll see wolf thank you for joining me
on 20 milliliters how are you
thank you mike this is a pleasure i'm
fine
thank you thank you very very much for
being here you'll see um let's let's
talk about consumer robotics let's let's
find you know what's happening in the
industry today and both understand your
own you know journey within robotics
this is not the first company that
you're building in this in the sector
and but now you know we're looking at a
changing world the way we interact with
technology is emerging in various ways
and you know you're you're looking at a
way of you know interacting with
technology in the physical world not
just in the software world which is
incredibly exciting and looking at
robots as personal assistants and so so
jose tell me a little bit about yourself
and you know your journey into robotics
and then we'll talk about this industry
as a whole okay pleasure so
i i'm like 20 years in the business of
robotics
i mean the practical you know revenue
based business of robotics which is
unique
because you see many robots you know on
youtube but you don't see many robots in
the real world
and i will explain
why robotics is like
probably the most advanced technology
it's a mix of everything
it's a lego of of you know the the human
limits in technologies
you have you know
optics ai control cloud
safety mechanics hardware you have it
all
and
and and and human you know is looking
for robots for from from the day of of
the pc invention
so it's like from one side you know the
image
imagination is there you know you want
to have a robot you know humanity wants
a robot and from the other side you
don't have robots
especially you don't have robots that
interact with human
so you have some you know vacuum
cleaners you have some industrial robots
that are connected to the you know to
the concrete floor and they assemble
cars but you don't have robots like you
envisioned 10 more watts
and i decided to meet this you know holy
grail of the challenges the the everest
of the challenges
and you should be a bit crazy
uh to do that it sounds like it all
all the big companies
historically failed
like google
acquired like 10 robotic companies in
2016 and failed
amazon robotics is not there yet you
know in warehousing yes but no human in
the loop once you have a human in the
loop it's a whole different story
uh you know not to mention the big boys
and and just lately you know tesla is
talking about robotics you know elon
musk revealed you know the service robot
is gonna come so i think that what is so
unique about robotics
is that human being you know they want
it
and just
in the last two years probably
you have the enablers the enablers are
there you know yeah so i think that
that speaks to you know my question okay
so why why didn't it work why did why
didn't the ten companies at google buy
why didn't they succeed you know we're
only talking about five years ago 2016
what's happening in the market
i think that you know this is
exponential you know development of
technology robotics is not a robot you
know a robot definition is is is very
fluid it's it's a
philosophical question
your wash machine you know and your
fridge there is also kind of a robot so
it doesn't matter the definition what
what matters is that the technology is
super advanced
super advanced what happened in the last
two years is that the ai
is coming big time
the cloud technologies you know up there
and today you can put you know endless
amount of algorithms literally and less
on the cloud and you can have a robot
device which is more like an iot device
which is more like just you know the
the end unit
and then you can get you know very high
performances for example you can talk
with a robot a robot can navigate you
know based on its cloud algorithms
meaning the price
is getting much lower
and the software you know got much
higher
the communication infrastructures became
much better
you know with 4g and 5g and high-speed
wi-fi which enabling you know the robot
to walk in real-time world
and you as a human you used to work in a
real-time world you know you have your
own natural speed and you have your own
you know things
so i think that these are the enablers
for robotics of course it's thanks to
the smartphone
so you have you know the internet
you have smartphones and next
is probably movement
because we are moving creatures so once
you're adding the movement you have you
you you get a concert
you get
a console and and this is this is a huge
challenge today we do see
thousands of robots that are coming
in different sectors
right so you'll see you're sitting there
and you're saying you know what i'm
gonna do this i'm going to i'm going to
create this consumer product that is
going to allow humans to have movement
with their technology
and and we have all these enablers that
we just talked about and it's going to
be great what do you do then how do you
even start thinking about okay how is
this going to look how is it going to
feel how is it going to interact how do
i sell this to consumers right how do
you go about thinking about all these
things
first of all i think it's pretty natural
it's more like you know from
i would say from life science than than
exact science
but
i give you know a short story of the
process so you know i've been in the
israelia for special forces for six
years i've been a
company commander
then i studied physics and philosophy in
tel aviv university
which always i was interested about you
know
what is going on in this world
just like to wonder
in parliament as a student i i met a
girl in a bar and she told me about her
father and her father you know he is to
have like a small startup company for
electro optics
i had no idea about you know nothing
and i started to walk there instead of
you know serving uh humble girls in tel
aviv restaurant
i started to work there as a
very low you know level student
and
very quickly i just i just fall in love
in in development
in r d you know r d for a guy like me
it's like a playground
you you can do you know so many things
the challenges are there it makes the
the quality of connections with our
colleagues
very strong because once the challenge
is
big
then
you see you know the right you know
personnel and the right
team
that you can achieve these challenges
and you cannot do it with anyone
and it makes the your time in life just
you know amazing and exciting
so i literally fell in love in in
development and
very quickly i became a
vp in this company
for robotics and we started to do some
things with robots but it was like in
2007-8
uh wow technology was very limited
and
in late 2009
i felt mature i was 29
and i saved like some capital started
from nothing i saved like
it's it's it's embarrassing to say but i
saved like 20 000 usd
and i said to myself okay what's now i
have a lot of money
so me and my co-founder
ilan
we decided to invest it all
all in no option to fail
no money from from home no support
into a company
that will do robotics
and we just were you know kids that
were thinking that
if the internet is so successful
in 2009 so for sure the next thing will
be you know 3d will be physical both
will be movement right and we both were
so excited about it and we just you know
put a list of robots you know robots for
agriculture robots for defense robots
for
elderly people robots for education
and uh and and and we did it you know we
just we just i quit a job with a very
high salary of a you know vp
and i put all of my money into a small
company named robo team
now today robo team is probably the
number one
not tammy robo team it's my my my first
company
probably the number one company in the
world
for life-saving robots
we generated more than you know 100
million us dollars in in sales we we we
provided thousands of
systems
that are saving lives today all around
the world
like we are the robotic company of of
israel
we are one of the providers prime
contractors of the us pentagon
like two guys from nothing we literally
were sitting in my partner's
grandmother's apartment to save the rent
we became a prime provider to the us
pentagon
and that was my high school
my high school was working with the us
pentagon literally
and
the mix you know the classic mix of
special forces and
curiosity and
and energy endless
i we became kind of experts for
robotics that can fight the hamas in
gaza that can go into the tunnels that
can go over the borders that can carry
away to our friends
and you know we live in a tough
neighborhood
so every time and then it was a big
operation you know lebanon and all this
that i don't like it at all
but that was my
our way to help
and it was perfect because it was
only a way to help it was only a way to
make money
it was also a way to have responsibility
over more than 100 employees
it was many things and and for me it was
just perfect
and
while doing that with robo team
after six years of being the ceo in vpr
day
uh and again i'm very curious guys so
you know i was excited working and
learning how the big industries are
working lb's and these and raphael and
and look at martin and
and everything and i i was spending many
hours at the
the pentagon
uh
for for a guy with a very israeli
english you know and
culture i became like a
expert for
robotics
in in the defense
so i then i decided that this was enough
for me after six years and i i'm still a
main shareholder over there and a
founder and a director but
i i
i had a vision
that i would like to have a bigger
impact
like the impact when you work with
governments you work with usually a
single organization
you know in each country
i wanted to work with everyone
and one day i went to visit my dear
grandmother at the time when she rest in
peace and and and and
i felt very connected to her
always and she she was you know spoiling
me and she was serving tea and cookies
and food
and she was 85 years old
and suddenly she was 100 percent fine
cognitive wise but she was shaking
you know
and it was you know hurtful to see yeah
and i went down to the store and i
bought a
walking device you know
and she said no way this is this isn't a
product for old people
i hate it
take it away
so i said okay okay uh
would you like to have a robot
she said yes that's cool
and that's where my market research
ended
literally
and i decided to devote my
life into this project
i knew that this is the almost
impossible project
because so many companies tried to do
that before
and failed
and
you know jumping on i succeeded to raise
close to 100 million u.s dollars into
this you know vision of
helping to elderly people with a robot
device
today
the name is tammy
um temi robot today
became more than that
it became
like
more like the iphone of robotics
it became like a platform
that you can use and customize to
different use cases in many sectors
the number one use is for elderly people
assistant and for remote care
but there are many more and along the
process working with my grandmother
we decided to make it cool we decided to
make it you know if we if i want it it's
okay if i i don't i if i don't want it
no
so so that's why the temi design is
superb and it's black and it's you know
state of the art it's a
it's the best of the best in software
and that's that's what happened
fortunately at the time i met
mr john woo who was the first investor
in alibaba
and co-founder of alibaba and the cto in
the first 10 years
and he came to israel in here and i met
him for five minutes and i told him the
same story that i'm telling to you
and he said you'll see let's do that
let's take your know-how from the
defense
and let's establish you know a
commercial
company
robotemi and i will open for you asia
and he invested within two weeks i heard
they're big into robots asia
yeah
and for me
again as a curious you know child
china was closed when you walk in the
defense there is no china china is like
iran
for the americans yep
but for me
it was so exciting suddenly all of asia
was open for me
and they are much more excited from
hardware in general
but for my robot's ideas
the acceptance was very high
i i fell in love in the culture and the
speed and the energy and i started to
visit the big factories
and and the price of tammy robot for
example is the price of the box
of a defense robot
so it's a different world of components
and and standards and whatever you want
so it was super exciting for me
and i decided to relocate
a few guys the best of the best from tel
aviv to china
five years ago and we opened temi china
and we have today 80 chinese employees
that are managing thousands of you know
assembly employees
in shenzhen which is like the chinese
silicon valley
and this is very unique this is very
unique story we have
the mother company is tel aviv which i'm
leading
and we have
subsidiaries both in china and the us
and i don't
know many companies that succeeded to
penetrate both markets
so we have thousands of robots today in
china
in chinese in their cloud in their world
which is like you know being on mars
and you are
the west world which is a different
world
working in in all over europe and in the
u.s markets as well
and we are the small israelis we are in
between
managing the whole you know product and
the old map of the product
so so that's that's in a nutshell you
know my story i am i'm passionate about
robots uh in in many fields in many
aspects it's only the beginning
there are maybe
four to five companies today on the
world level
that sells you know thousands of robots
uh
with what we call men in the loop
service robots in the indoor
environments
we are the only one from the west
all of them
trainees
because you know many reasons we not
talk about it but but we are a very very
unique israeli company
that made it big in hardware
uh
by by understanding the challenge and by
relocating the best guys to include a
ceo
to china
to manage the operation from there
unbelievable you'll see i think that the
it's not just the story of you know
entrepreneurship and business but it's a
story of
you know of an entrepreneur that is
solving a problem that they have to
solve and you said a sentence before
that really touched me with that you're
dedicating your life to this this is not
you know your second company this is not
another business that you're running
this is a life mission and and obviously
i'm sure that it translates to your
conversation with john woo and and and
his willingness to to jump in on this uh
and and and devote both massive capital
but also i'm sure time and energy and
and you know emotional energy and and
getting the best people around you to to
go on this journey and and at the end
penetrating you know the two biggest
markets in the world for this and uh and
doing so in in a way that you know that
actually works and and having those
wallets deployed and and sent over and i
think that it's a it's it's a fantastic
story and very inspiring for young
entrepreneurs so thank you very very
much for sharing with me and thank you
for spending this time with me thank you
for these 20 minutes and and i wish you
really the best of luck with tammy and i
can't wait to to have one of those
robots for myself as well one day
and and thank you very much thank you
mike it was a pleasure